[Musique]
or
jamais le valhalla n'a été aussi
affaiblie
j'entends respirer les ténèbres dans
respire
les dieux sont divisés
faisait longtemps que j'attendais que
l'enfant de la lumière vienne sauver le
une guerre de milan a plongé le valhalla
dans les ténèbres
le rock
tu as peur peut-être ta je verrai sur
toi
le loup fenrir a réussi à s'échapper si
jamais les gens tout notre monde n'en
ont rappelé pour longtemps
à toi
la destinée des connus de personne
que tous les guerriers se tient prêt
ton voyage ne fait que commencer
nous sommes les hommes capables
d'empêcher la prophétie france
plus bas
seul son marteau sera capable de venir à
bout de perdre le fil
côté devenu flic toi me dis pas que ces
sacs tous les faire quand tu étais petit
non je les taquine baroin
et comme on est passé du patin au
flingue
je sais pas ça s'est fait comme ça
allez bonne journée je te crois pas
et vous crise en grèce moi je pense pas
comme s'il y avait un désert dans ma
tête j'ai pas de messie comme personne
cherche à d'artistique cependant
souffler et j'avance l'odeur de mort on
a beau se savonner s'est par contre
quand je rentre le soir udc estiment
jusqu'à 60 message c'est pas rentrer
toute cette merde chez moi un gars doit
être présenté à la viande en trois
heures c'est nous qui faisons la
reconduit de 31 points mais c'est pas
notre boulot
pourquoi ça nous faire ça c'est le type
avec le pull orange méfiez vous quand
même
ils vont tuer pourquoi une décision
d'expulsion a été prise si on était
certain qu'il allait se faire buter à
son retour
eddie puise exagère les menaces pour
avoir leur statut de réfugiés comme on
fait la différence entre un réfugié un
terroriste
tu fais rien d'envoyer règlement et moi
le [ __ ] c'est ça qui obéit aux ordres
c'est mon boulot figurez-vous justin
post
pas de couilles au cul en fait pâle et
yann toucan
ritchie personne n'était pas ce que je
fais preuve du contraire
vingt ans de service pas une tache au
dossier il a fallu vous foutu la merde
[Musique]
oui je crois
le moment est arrivé
[Musique]
et il arrive
[Applaudissements]
ouais
g
divin selphy août acculèrent jeu toute
ta vie tatoué sur mon temps ouais
il en a mangé un
tout ça fait plaisir qui va sérieusement
falloir travailler ta force et son
endurance
heureusement j'ai la solution quoi
oui alors non ça va pas être possible
[Musique]
on essaye encore
on est mal au ca cauchemar
on souhaite mettre fin aux cherry
t'embrasse papa
mes parents m'ont bien fait quand on
veut la caisse n'a jamais fait l'amour
avec un papillon
[Musique]
excusez moi je voulais juste zion qui
vole quand en fait vous ratez rien
avec des amis oui alberto fait quoi dans
l'origine je suis restaurateur c'est le
pizzaïolo dutendas rue voyez le truc de
bon goût avec des gondoles des détours
épices intérieur c'est quoi ça mais ce
que vous faites là pas de nom mais vous
êtes des français en fait j'avais quoi
notons que ça comme une autoroute elle
est où ma soeur je pense à vous et aux
enfants tient lundi que le bonheur est
possible en faisait pas devenu fou ce
matin
nous avoir ici tous c'est formidable
je voudrais marin pour avoir votre vie
comme on vient d'arriver là on en est
arrivé là bas si quelqu'un passe et
c'est tout
combien
[Musique]
alors tu voudrais toujours un pour avoir
ma vie encore plus depuis je sais que tu
te tapes et alberto
[Musique]
oui aux vagues au perchoir les deux cas
cameron
las
[Musique]
ah non non non je non je peux plus faire
l'amour avec vous messieurs je le serai
quand même vous m'avez offert wind donc
à ce moment là je vous ai proposé de
venir dormir chez moi on a fait
commencer une vidéo mais qu'est ce que
c'est que ça qu'est-ce que c'était
ridicule moi parce que je suis breton ma
grand mère a inventé la galette saucisse
sextet vous pouvez casser ça tout de
suite si je vous faire chanter je ferai
passer
[Musique]
la fidh et le contact d'un hacker s'ils
pouvaient phase est celle là aussi c'est
ma fille c'est un portable de la gauche
après la vidéo vous écris 42 lettre
recommandée à facebook
aucune réponse rien je pourrais tu as vu
comme ça pourrit la mienne je vais te
spoiler la face moi tu vois c'est sur
l'application payante
iam taxi driver à need more north star
une colonne toulouse c'est pire qu'à
bracelet électronique cette mère elle a
prié
[Musique]
vidéo qui sont partis à l'enfer comme
patrick becker sécurié voile et
certaines n'ont pas pris leur prince en
place par un maire départ de datacenter
act of tara
les leurs
ces moments ne t'a pas mon nom dans
internet s'il te plait je n'arrive pas
[Musique]
non j'ai plus de réseau bonjour madame
vous reliez largement au dessus de la
limite de vitesse
monsieur monsieur vous m'entendez
marchal james dillon je présume moi
c'est diablo cette ville est à moi
alors c'est dans ce trou vous avez
atterri après avoir buté votre
coéquipier pour ça qu'ils portent plus
de flingues vous n'avez pas intérêt à
blesser qui que ce soit est ce que je me
suis fait comprendre qu est ce que tu
veux ou la chambre en forme car rien
d'autre à voler ici your head quoi dans
28 minutes si un fourgon blindé au
moindre souci préviendront la police
d'état ça c'est ce qu'on verra
je vais vous envoyer au trot il va
falloir me buter
si tu as besoin je vois que tu as pensé
à tout
balance of luck quote moi
abb
oyster sonabhy partez vite changer
[Musique]
c'est alors que les mauvais
m
et
[Musique]
il
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]